what a great honor to have this man he
is the former executive director of the
aclu who was featured in the documentary
mighty ira a civil liberty story ira
glasser
sir
how are you
i won't shake your hands but i wish i
could
[Applause]
of all the people who've sat in that
chair you're the ones i really want to
shake a hand or give you a hug because i
would i feel like you've affected my
life as head of the aculu and being so
such a great protector of free speech
which is my business
it sure is it sure is and i am very
aware always have been that i've been
able to really enjoy free speech
especially here on hbo
at abc before they fired me
but in general
and comedians weren't always i i mean
you've been with the acu a long time
were you there when lenny bruce was
going through his problems no not quite
not quite but you're aware he had like
yes
nine trials right
they put him on trial for things that
every comic now says openly
so where's the acl well you know they
put they they tried to prosecute people
for wearing
uh flag shirts american flag shirts
now you see american flag
decals on everything right people make
underwear out of it toilet paper out of
it but in the sixties they prosecuted
people for full so you were ahead of
this organization excuse me for 25 years
almost i mean from 1978 to into this
century right um
it's changing i mean it was a stalwart
defender of free speech and civil
liberties is it still that
not as much
um
i mean
they they just produced a couple of
years ago
new guidelines
for their lawyers to use when deciding
what free speech cases to take this is a
requirement now for the national aclu
lawyers that before they take a
case defending someone's free speech
they have to make sure that the speech
doesn't
offend or threaten other
civil liberties values
in other words in other words
before they're going to defend your free
speech they want to see what you say
and that's the aclu no that's the
government what is the aclu doing so i
read that quote then the phrase was
values contrary to
our values our values but your value is
free speech yeah i mean you the most
famous case you defended the nazis being
able to march in skokie illinois in 1977
right okay
i'm guessing the nazis did not reflect
your values
that's a good guess right
actually
actually
most of the speech we defended didn't
affect of course
that's what it is that's the point that
is the point and you mentioned the flag
this is the problem i think that humans
have but now they have a bigger problem
with it than they did in the old days
when they were more sophisticated
there's concepts like free speech
and then there's nazis and flags which
are concrete and you see a nazi
you see a flag burning you don't like it
or if you're anti-tobacco you see a
tobacco ad and you don't like that or if
right or if you're
uh for women's equality you see
playboy magazine you don't like that
people used to say to me isn't it hard
to defend free speech when so few people
in this country are in favor of it and
my response always was no that's wrong
everybody's in favor of free speech as
long as it's theirs right
and and um everybody has an exception
uh everybody says well i believe in free
speech but
right and it doesn't work if there are
exceptions i mean can i show a quote
from the current head anthony romero i'm
sure you're familiar with this gentleman
he said i reject that we need an
entrance exam
on civil liberties to establish the
bonafides needed to work here
what
you don't need an entrance exam on civil
liberties in an organization called the
american civil liberties union
would you like to address him directly
well you know
that might be true for hiring people to
work
in the xerox room
he's not talking about that no that's
exactly that's exactly but you know if
you're hiring a lawyer to defend the
first amendment you want to have a
reasonable assumption that he likes the
first amendment what that he supports it
for if you're hiring word knows about it
okay i mean you know
if you
if you're hiring if you're hiring
somebody if you're hiring a lawyer to
defend reproductive choice for women
you want to be reasonably certain
that they believe in reproductive choice
now sure it's possible
for a good lawyer to defend things that
he or she doesn't believe in
but at a cause organization like the
aclu it wasn't so much that you were
doing an entrance exam but why would you
want to hire somebody who who
didn't agree with with what you were
pushing
i
i it seems like i mean organizations do
drift
right i mean the republican party used
to be about small government and lower
taxes and now it's become an
authoritarian personality cult i would
call that adrift
we see it in television you know uh
networks don't even do what their name
says like mtv was music television they
have no more music
you know the learning channel had sarah
palin on
well
really that's a lesson
that's a good lesson um well you know
the asia the asia u has has become not
totally this is not a hundred to nothing
but they've become more of a
political partisan what they call
progressive organization now they
organizations have the right to change
they can do that but the problem is
there isn't any other aclu
and if there isn't somebody who's
prepared to defend what you say and
prepare to defend what the nazis say and
prepare to defend what people for
abortion say and prepare to defend what
people who are against abortion say
then the government gets to decide who
can speak and that's the most dangerous
thing
you